Alice: 火小一点
Alice: Turn the heat down a bit.
Tasha:  火已经很小了
Tasha: The heat is already low.
Alice: 你锅里是不是有油
Alice: Do you have oil in the pan?
Alice: 哎不对
Alice: Oh, wait.
Alice: 有水
Alice: There's water.
Tasha:  没有我已经把水抽干了
Tasha: No, I already drained the water.
Lucia: 这锅昨天是不是用过呀
Lucia: Was this pan used yesterday?
Tasha:  我靠这锅怎么这么倒
Tasha: Damn, why is this pan so tilted?
Tasha:  倒热怎么这么快
Tasha: It heats up so fast.
Alice: 它比较薄
Alice: It's pretty thin.
Tasha:  拿一个那个小小小碟子来呗
Tasha: Get a small plate for the pancakes.
Tasha:  放这些饼
Tasha: To put these pancakes on.
Alice: 好
Alice: Sure.
Alice: 露西亚你就不用帮我热了吧
Alice: Lucia, you don't need to heat it for me.
Alice: 倒直接倒就行了
Alice: Just pour it straight in.
Alice: 给你
Alice: Here you go.
Alice: 笑死了这个这个
Alice: This is hilarious.
Alice: 手机拍的好整齐你看
Alice: The phone took such neat photos, look.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 像开会一样
Alice: It's like a meeting.
Tasha:  开会上交手机
Tasha: Hand in your phones at meetings.
Lucia: 手机开会
Lucia: Phone meetings.
Tasha:  也不知道熟了没
Tasha: No idea if it's cooked.
Tasha:  外面都糊了
Tasha: It's burnt on the outside.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Alice: 没
Alice: No.
Alice: 这太短了时间
Alice: The time was too short.
Tasha:  那只能用小火煎了
Tasha: We can only use low heat to fry it.
Tasha:  看看不清了都没关系
Tasha: It's okay if we can't see clearly.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's fine.
Alice: 你看这里面还爆浆呢
Alice: Look, it's even oozing inside.
Lucia: 这这这这瓶昨天没开过吗
Lucia: Did we open this bottle yesterday?
Alice: 当然没熟
Alice: Of course, it's not cooked.
Lucia: 你昨天没有开牛奶吗
Lucia: Didn't you open the milk yesterday?
Lucia: 应该开过一瓶吧
Lucia: You should have opened a bottle.
Lucia: 先把开的那瓶喝了
Lucia: Finish the opened bottle first.
Alice: 看里面都不熟呢
Alice: Look, it's still not cooked inside.
Tasha:  外面都已经这么黑了
Tasha: The outside is already so burnt.
Alice: 油一点点大哈
Alice: The oil is a bit too much, huh?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice: 太厚了没关系没关系
Alice: It's too thick, but it's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 把那个外面面的那个丢掉就行
Alice: Just throw away the outer layer and it's fine.
Tasha:  OK第一个饼先给杨老板吃
Tasha: OK, let's give the first pancake to Jake.
Tasha:  我这个锅怎么回事
Tasha: What's wrong with this pan?
Tasha:  太可怕了
Tasha: It's terrifying.
Alice: 你要不给弄开吧好
Alice: Do you want to open it up?
Tasha:  好你看看熟了没
Tasha: Okay, check if it's cooked.
Alice: 勉强
Alice: Barely.
Lucia: 奥
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我怎么每次开门都会掉点东西下来啊
Lucia: Why do I always drop something every time I open the door?
Tasha:  没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha:  我来把这个也也也剪开
Tasha: I'll cut this one as well.
Lucia: 你放这了呀
Lucia: You put it here?
Lucia: 我可以用一下另一个灶吗
Lucia: Can I use the other stove?
Tasha:  要要用微波炉
Tasha: You need to use the microwave.
Tasha:  呃呃好吧
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Tasha:  这个也可以了
Tasha: This one is ready too.
Lucia: 微波炉打吗
Lucia: Microwave it?
Lucia: 微波炉打不知道能不能打的透
Lucia: Not sure if the microwave can cook it thoroughly.
Lucia: 而且没事就放在这吧
Lucia: Anyway, just leave it here.
Lucia: 然后大家再倒出来就好
Lucia: Then everyone can pour it out later.
Tasha:  啊这个锅太可怕了
Tasha: Ah, this pan is terrifying.
Lucia: 哎这个灶台
Lucia: Hey, this stove.
Alice: 露西亚你准备的是几个人的牛奶
Alice: Lucia, how much milk did you prepare?
Lucia: 呃没事我们可以随便倒哈哈
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, we can just pour it freely, haha.
Alice: 啊因为我想喝凉的
Alice: Ah, because I want to drink it cold.
Lucia: 你想喝凉的
Lucia: You want it cold?
Lucia: 呃有还有
Lucia: Uh, there's more.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 对就是呃不用算我的量啊
Lucia: Yeah, just don't count my portion.
Alice: 就是不用算我的量就可以了
Alice: Just don't count my portion, that's fine.
Lucia: 没事那就如果多了的话
Lucia: No worries, if there's too much,
Lucia: 大家一会多喝一点就好了哈哈
Lucia: everyone can just drink a bit more later, haha.
Alice: 啊好
Alice: Ah, okay.
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 就是那个那个已经打开的我也没倒完
Lucia: The one that's already open, I haven't finished it yet.
Lucia: 然后假如你不够喝
Lucia: And if you don't have enough to drink,
Lucia: 你也可以打开那个新的
Lucia: you can open a new one.
Alice: 啊不用谢谢
Alice: Oh, no need, thanks.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No worries, no worries.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful.
Lucia: 哦这个OK
Lucia: Oh, this one is okay.
Lucia: 咦
Lucia: Eh?
Alice: 这个我自己倒吧
Alice: I'll pour this myself.
Lucia: 这个火太大了
Lucia: This fire is too strong.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 然后我看看
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 我们牛奶应该是要用杯子
Lucia: We should use cups for the milk.
Lucia: 我把剩下这几杯子都洗了
Lucia: I'll wash the remaining cups.
Alice: 我直接用碗了
Alice: I'll just use a bowl.
Lucia: 也可以哈哈
Lucia: That works too, haha.
Lucia: 这个任君选择
Lucia: Whatever you prefer.
Lucia: 23234 那我们剩下有 4个
Lucia: 23234, so we have 4 left.
Lucia: 四个人的话
Lucia: For the four of us,
Alice: 外国人一点震撼
Alice: Foreigners are a bit shocked.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 雨轩你要单喝纯牛奶吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to drink pure milk?
Lucia: 还是你还喝你刚才的咖啡哦
Lucia: Or do you want to continue with your coffee?
Katrina:  用我就喝我自己这个就行
Katrina: I'll just drink my own.
Lucia: 好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 那我们就三个杯子哎
Lucia: Then we'll just need three cups.
Lucia: 那牛奶可能稍微有点多
Lucia: We might have a bit too much milk.
Alice: 没事喝不完可以给我
Alice: It's okay, if there's any left, I can drink it.
Lucia: 啊可以哈哈你可以等他凉了再喝
Lucia: Sure, haha, you can drink it when it cools down.
Lucia: 或者我们多喝一点
Lucia: Or we can drink a bit more.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: No worries.
Alice: 我只是比较喜欢喝凉的
Alice: I just prefer it cold.
Lucia: 我和薇薇多喝一点
Lucia: Tasha and I will drink more.
Lucia: 因为那个靖康他好像也要喝咖啡
Lucia: Because Jingkang also wants to drink coffee.
Tasha:  OK第二次做的是薄饼
Tasha: Okay, the second time we made pancakes.
Alice: 你你那个离他远一点
Alice: You, you, move away from it a bit.
Alice: 因为怕熏到你的眼镜
Alice: So it doesn't smoke up your glasses.
Tasha:  颠勺颠勺
Tasha: Flip the wok, flip the wok.
Alice: 哎哎小心点小心点啊
Alice: Hey, hey, be careful, be careful!
Tasha:  我靠太可怕了
Tasha: Oh my gosh, this is so scary.
Lucia: 哦我在把我手机的
Lucia: Oh, I'm turning on my phone's...
Lucia: 铃声打开
Lucia: ...ringtone.
Lucia: 要不然一会万一外卖到了的话
Lucia: Otherwise, if the delivery arrives...
Lucia: 我听不见
Lucia: ...I won't hear it.
Tasha:  熟了吗熟了好像
Tasha: Is it cooked? It looks cooked.
Lucia: 我昨天的那个卡让我放哪去了
Lucia: Where did I put that card from yesterday?
Alice: 哎小心点怎么了
Alice: Hey, be careful, what's going on?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha:  没事
Tasha: Nothing.
Alice: 这给它搁哪呢
Alice: Where should we put this?
Alice: 咋了我看看
Alice: What's up, let me see.
Tasha:  锅溅油了
Tasha: The oil splashed from the pot.
Tasha:  这真是一个脾气不好的锅
Tasha: This is really an ill-tempered pot.
Alice: 可以等油没那么热的时候就放进去
Alice: You can wait until the oil isn't so hot before putting it in.
Tasha:  我关小火了他还是崩了
Tasha: I turned down the heat, but it's still splashing.
Alice: 油太热的那啥嗯
Alice: The oil is too hot, that's why...
Alice: 因为我们那个面粉里有含水吗
Alice: Because our flour has water in it, right?
Tasha: 含
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 应该好了别烧的时间太久给他烧开了
Lucia: It should be done. Don't cook it too long or it'll boil over.
Lucia: sorry把它拿走小心手
Lucia: Sorry, let's move it. Be careful with your hands.
Alice: 筷子竟然不是一样长的
Alice: The chopsticks aren't the same length.
Alice: 这就顺眼了
Alice: Now it looks right.
Alice: 露西亚你把它拿起来一下
Alice: Lucia, can you lift it up a bit?
Alice: 因为这个桌布应该不耐高温
Alice: Because this tablecloth isn't heat-resistant.
Lucia: 把这个稍微往中间放一点
Lucia: Move this a bit more to the center.
Lucia: 啊不过一会中间还要放蛋饼
Lucia: Ah, but we still need to put the egg pancakes in the middle later.
Lucia: 也不需要那么中间放一会吧
Lucia: Maybe we don't need to put it exactly in the center for now.
Lucia: 然后把这边上稍微挪一下
Lucia: And then move this side a little.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one...
Lucia: 这是你的咖啡吗
Lucia: Is this your coffee?
Alice: 我已经倒进去了
Alice: I already poured it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 那这个应该是刚才给靖康拿出来的
Lucia: Then this must be the one I took out for Jingkang.
Lucia: 给他放回去
Lucia: I'll put it back for him.
Lucia: 他一会下来了再拿吧
Lucia: He can get it when he comes down later.
Lucia: 要不然东桌上东西太多了
Lucia: Otherwise, there'll be too much stuff on the table.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 这个放走
Lucia: Let's let this one go.
Alice: 很棒
Alice: Great
Tasha:  已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: We've already made peace with him.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Tasha:  我说已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I said we've already made peace with him.
Alice: 那我帮你把这个洗了吧
Alice: Let me help you wash this.
Alice: 给你做收尾工作
Alice: I'll finish this up for you.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  这也挺简单
Katrina: This is quite simple too.
Alice: 先搁哪呢
Alice: Where should we put it first?
Katrina:  好像幼儿园舞蹈
Katrina: Looks like a kindergarten dance.
Katrina:  好啊哈哈
Katrina: Haha, yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 对这个这个音乐比较比较比较可爱
Lucia: Yeah, this music is quite cute.
Katrina:  啊他们有3个
Katrina: Ah, they have three of them.
Katrina:  等我给你看我跳了几个
Katrina: Wait, let me show you how many I danced.
Katrina:  哎这个
Katrina: Hey, this one.
Tasha:  喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha:  啊不用接听
Tasha: Ah, no need to answer.
Katrina:  12345刚好5个人
Katrina: 12345, exactly five people.
Katrina:  这节奏比刚刚那个快一点
Katrina: This rhythm is a bit faster than the previous one.
Katrina:  那个就自拍动的太慢
Katrina: The other one was too slow for a selfie.
Lucia: 这个音乐真的好幼儿园
Lucia: This music really feels like kindergarten.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina:  但只有这种就大家都能都听过的音乐
Katrina: But it's only these kinds of music that everyone has heard.
Katrina:  才能
Katrina: That can...
Lucia: 现在可以倒了吗感觉可以倒出来了
Lucia: Can we pour it out now? It feels like it's ready.
Alice: 关火了吗
Alice: Did you turn off the heat?
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Alice: 翻面了吧该
Alice: Should we flip it over?
Tasha:  嗯我看一下
Tasha: Hmm, let me check.
Lucia: 哎还是比较合适是的
Lucia: Ah, it's quite fitting, yes.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay
Katrina:  怎么没有独舞了又
Katrina: Why isn't there a solo dance again?
Lucia: 后面这段的音乐好像
Lucia: The music in this part seems like...
Katrina:  但是他独舞不多
Katrina: But there aren't many solo dances.
Katrina:  我再找一个叫什么奔跑的青春
Katrina: I'll find another one called "Running Youth."
Alice: 熟了吧
Alice: Is it done?
Tasha: 熟了
Tasha: It's done.
Alice:吃吧
Alice: Eat it.
Lucia: 我我投这个一票
Lucia: I vote for this one.
Lucia: 我觉得这个鼓点强一些
Lucia: I think the drumbeat is stronger.
Katrina:  嗯嗯但这这个怕他们有点学不会
Katrina: Hmm, but I'm afraid they might not be able to learn it.
Katrina:  动作还挺多
Katrina: There are quite a lot of moves.
Katrina:  这确实好看哈哈哈
Katrina: This really looks good, haha.
Lucia: 对而且这个鼓点强一些
Lucia: Yeah, and the drumbeat is stronger.
Lucia: 就是他这个节奏其实更好
Lucia: The rhythm is actually better.
Katrina:  嗯那我们看能不能扣个几分
Katrina: Hmm, let's see if we can deduct some points.
Katrina:  扣个1分多
Katrina: Deduct one point or more.
Lucia: 或者可以把就是难度高一点的动作
Lucia: Or we could remove the more difficult moves.
Lucia: 给他删掉
Lucia: Just delete them.
Katrina:  改了
Katrina: Change it.
Lucia: 对重新编一下
Lucia: Yeah, rearrange it.
Lucia: 我们可以从这段开始
Lucia: We can start from this part.
Lucia: 我觉得这对
Lucia: I think this is right.
Lucia: 然后这个就是前面出现过的那一部分
Lucia: And then this part has appeared before.
Lucia: 就是可以省略掉一些
Lucia: So we can skip some of it.
Lucia: 就是比较强那个什么的
Lucia: Just the strong parts or something.
Alice: 我拿个充电宝
Alice: I'll get a power bank.
Alice: 我怕这个没电
Alice: I'm afraid this will run out of battery.
Tasha:  行
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 充电宝在哪里嘞
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Katrina:  哎那就前边
Katrina: It's just in the front.
Katrina:  刚前面的
Katrina: Just in the front.
Lucia: 突然breaking了起来哈哈
Lucia: Suddenly started breaking, haha.
Katrina:  对要不就前面1分半看看
Katrina: Yeah, let's check the first 1 minute and a half.
Katrina: 感觉 1分多够拍
Katrina: Feels like 1 minute or so is enough to shoot.
Katrina:  哈哈够够呛
Katrina: Haha, barely enough.
Tasha:  谁用碗喝咖啡呢
Tasha: Who drinks coffee with a bowl?
Alice:我
Alice: I do.
Tasha:  aha
Tasha: Aha.
Tasha:  好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oh.
Katrina:  到底在哪跳啊
Katrina: Where exactly are we dancing?
Katrina:  外面还是二楼啊
Katrina: Outside or on the second floor?
Lucia: 可能是外面吧
Lucia: Maybe outside?
Lucia: 但是其我在想是外面没有什么舞台
Lucia: But I was thinking there's no stage outside.
Katrina:  外面是石子哎
Katrina: Outside is gravel.
Lucia: 然后二楼又不够宽敞
Lucia: And the second floor isn't spacious enough.
Lucia: 如果我们五六个人的话是很宽敞
Lucia: If there are five or six of us, it's pretty spacious.
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  外面还是石子哎那只能在这跳
Katrina: Outside, it's still gravel, so we can only dance here.
Katrina:  那天就可以在这跳
Katrina: We can dance here that day.
Lucia: 队形变化
Lucia: Formation change.
Lucia: 上面就大家就一直站着
Lucia: Everyone just stands up there.
Lucia: 不要变队形了就就排好哈哈
Lucia: No need to change the formation, just line up, haha.
Katrina:  这不用编队形啊
Katrina: No need for formation here.
Katrina:  就在这啊
Katrina: Just here.
Jake: 这是舞台
Jake: This is the stage.
Jake: 是吧在这围观
Jake: Right, we watch from here.
Katrina:  这是舞台
Katrina: This is the stage.
Katrina:  因为二楼太小了嘛
Katrina: Because the second floor is too small.
Katrina:  那肯定晚上跳舞在外面跳
Katrina: So, we'll definitely dance outside at night.
Katrina:  这10哎刚好就在这
Katrina: This 10, it's just right here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但我感觉这里这也只能站平着站
Lucia: But I feel like here we can only stand in a straight line.
Katrina:  哎只有5个人撒开
Katrina: Only 5 people can spread out.
Lucia: 我们没法前后站人
Lucia: We can't stand front and back.
Lucia: 对吧我感觉
Lucia: Right? That's how I feel.
Katrina:  2个差不多最
Katrina: Two is about the most.
Jake: 下面也站几个
Jake: A few can stand below too.
Katrina:  多站两排吧
Katrina: Let's make two rows.
Jake: 下面站几个会摔着吗
Jake: Will standing below make anyone fall?
Katrina:  可以前三后二这种
Katrina: We can do three in front, two in the back.
Lucia: 下面下面不能站对
Lucia: Below, we can't stand, right.
Jake: 不能站人
Jake: No standing below.
Lucia: 下面不好跳
Lucia: It's hard to dance below.
Katrina:  前三后二那种
Katrina: Three in front, two in the back.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 前三后二也可以
Lucia: Three in front, two in the back works too.
Katrina:  还行动作幅度小
Katrina: And the movements are smaller.
Lucia: 对就是
Lucia: Right, exactly.
Lucia: 可以不用
Lucia: We can avoid that.
Lucia: 就是整个就是怎么形容的
Lucia: The whole thing, how do I describe it.
Lucia: 就是他这个队列间间距不用很大
Lucia: The spacing in the lineup doesn't need to be big.
Lucia: 就是可能前三个人稍微往前点
Lucia: Maybe the three in front move a bit forward.
Lucia: 后两个人稍微往后一点点
Lucia: And the two in the back move a bit back.
Lucia: 就是一点1.5排的那种那种间距就可以了
Lucia: Just a 1.5 row spacing should be fine.
Jake: 挺好这边再搞一个舞台幕布
Jake: Great, let's put a stage curtain here too.
Lucia: 啊可以把投影搬到外面来吗
Lucia: Ah, can we move the projector outside?
Jake: 不是就是一个幕
Jake: No, it's just a screen.
Jake: 嗯布就是真实的physical的一个布
Jake: Yeah, the screen is just a real physical fabric.
Katrina:  那你得买一个这种
Katrina: Then you'll need to buy one like this.
Jake: 在这一挂
Jake: Hang it here.
Jake: 对这布以前买过挺多
Jake: Yeah, I used to buy a lot of these fabrics.
Jake: 20多块钱一个
Jake: About 20 bucks each.
Jake: 这么大的
Jake: This big.
Lucia: 像影像那个影棚的那种吗
Lucia: Like the kind used in photo studios?
Katrina:  量一下午
Katrina: Measure it for an afternoon.
Katrina:  网上找吗
Katrina: Find it online?
Jake: 对就是广告打广告
Jake: Yeah, just for advertising.
Jake: 那个村门口的那种大广告你知道吗
Jake: You know those big ads at the village entrance?
Lucia: 哦哈哈哈哈可以
Lucia: Oh, hahaha, sure.
Jake: 哦哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, hahaha.
Lucia: 我们可以想想
Lucia: We can think about it.
Lucia: 上面要什么花纹或者颜色的
Lucia: What pattern or color should be on it?
Jake: 这什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: "Youth Running."
Katrina:  哈哈但是还没决定好几个
Katrina: Haha, but we haven't decided on a few yet.
Katrina:  要看一下大家难度
Katrina: Need to see how difficult it is for everyone.
Katrina:  猪猪侠那个有点慢我觉得
Katrina: The "Pig Hero" one is a bit slow, I think.
Katrina:  拿筷子了吗
Katrina: Did you get the chopsticks?
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Jake: 我又被diss了
Jake: I got dissed again.
Jake: 你又diss我哈哈
Jake: You're dissing me again, haha.
Jake: 总不回他的消息
Jake: Always not replying to his messages.
Jake: 他让我吃早饭
Jake: He wants me to eat breakfast.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: He's impressive.
Tasha:  这还牛哦别看了
Tasha: Impressive? Stop watching.
Tasha:  哈哈哈这锅烧导热性太好
Tasha: Hahaha, this pot conducts heat too well.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 哦导多了
Jake: Oh, it conducted too much.
Lucia: 我觉得这一看就很好吃
Lucia: I think it looks delicious.
Jake: 是啊我不会
Jake: Yeah, I can't do it.
Tasha:  不不会
Tasha: No, you can't.
Jake: 为啥不会就会
Jake: Why can't I? I can.
Lucia: 这个牛奶是你的了
Lucia: This milk is yours.
Tasha:  我没有信心
Tasha: I have no confidence.
Jake: 试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia: 然后如果需要加咖啡请自行加
Lucia: If you need more coffee, please add it yourself.
Lucia: 因为我不知道你要喝多浓
Lucia: Because I don't know how strong you like it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Tasha:  加糖
Tasha: Add sugar.
Alice: 给你露西亚你的碗
Alice: Here you go, Lucia, your bowl.
Jake: 糖在哪
Jake: Where's the sugar?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice: 我拿一下吧
Alice: I'll get it.
Tasha:  糖糖糖蘸糖
Tasha: Sugar, sugar, dip the sugar.
Lucia: 这个碗
Lucia: This bowl.
Lucia: 少一个没事我再拿一个好了
Lucia: Missing one is fine, I'll get another one.
Alice: 我我不要
Alice: No, I don't need it.
Alice: 我的已经结束了
Alice: I'm done.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Alice: 我碗都刷完了
Alice: I've washed all the bowls.
Lucia: 那我就先拿走一个这个
Lucia: Then I'll take this one for now.
Alice: 拿个纸擦一下
Alice: Grab a paper towel and wipe it.
Alice: 放放这个放糖吧
Alice: Put, put the sugar here.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 要什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Alice: 这这里面不是放糖蘸的吗
Alice: Isn't the sugar for dipping?
Alice: 还是自己倒自己碗里
Alice: Or pour it into your own bowl.
Tasha:  这是自己的碗
Tasha: This is my own bowl.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: 我提前一两天买票已经挺极限了
Alice: 就是别人可能他一放票
Alice: 或者说是提前几天就是放票的
Alice: 提前几天
Alice: 可能就一共推往前推个一二十天
Alice: 就开始抢了
Alice: 然后我大学的时候也是
Alice: 他们都已经开始想
Alice: 哪天抢哪天的票了
Alice: 然后每次都是快回家了
Alice: 我想要不看看票吧
Alice: 一看啦啦啦售罄哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈是
Alice: 好吧
Jake: 是有一次我回家飞南京然后
Jake: 就没赶上嘛
Jake: 自然而然没有赶上
Jake: 呃那一天最后
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个是我最爱
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈自然而然
Tasha: 自然而然没赶上
Lucia: 哈
Jake: 对自然而然没有赶上
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake: 所以所以那天看的最后一班
Jake: 回中国了
Jake: 先到了成都
Alice: 哈哈哈
Jake: 对到了成都待了一晚上
Jake: 我觉得成都到南京应该高铁也挺快
Tasha:  然后也没赶上
Katrina:  很很远很远
Katrina:  1,800公里
Jake: 对我我我以为挺快的
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 因为我想北京也挺
Alice: 哈哈
Jake: 就差不多距离吧
Jake: 对吧大概有几个小时
Tasha:  啊然后赶上好吗
Jake: 结果要那个是飞机场买的所以
Jake: 赶上哈哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 就是去到成都之对那
Jake: 那个是买到了成都之后
Jake: 一晚上就在这个春熙路晃悠了一晚上
Jake: 然后因为第二天早上的飞机
Jake: 然后就飞走了
Jake: 原来想坐高铁的
Jake: 结果
Jake: 那个高铁大概也得七八个小时是吧
Katrina:  没有高铁
Katrina:  成都到武汉都要9个小时
Katrina:  武汉到南京还要2 3个小时
Alice: 它那个线路不一定
Katrina:  但是但是10小时以上
Jake: 太可怕了
Katrina:  我一般都是买的飞机票
Katrina:  我当时也以为
Katrina:  我以为那个武汉长沙
Katrina:  成都是挨在一起的
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina:  武汉跟长沙只有一个小时
Katrina:  但是到到川渝那就很远
Katrina:  就要6个小时
Jake: 要绕一圈
Jake: 我也觉得应该挺近
Jake: 我也觉得这个中国高铁应该没这么
Lucia: 对
Jake: 哈哈哈没这么慢
Alice: 哈哈哈
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Jake: 我高铁有十几个小时
Lucia: 居然成都到武汉比成都到北京还慢
Lucia: 总感觉好像
Lucia: 感觉上应该就是他到北京更远一些
Alice: 现高铁是不是降过速了
Lucia: 成都到北京应该是8个多小
Lucia: 嗯
Alice: 现在高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: 现在一般都300多了
Jake: 对都是300对
Alice: 嗯都是300多
Jake: 300整怎么
Tasha:  太离谱了
Tasha:  他帮我找出来了北京到郑州的公交票
Alice: 啊
Lucia: 哈
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Alice: 什么
Jake: 倒多少趟
Alice: 告诉我哈哈
Tasha:  我说我说如果我不去
Jake: 哎狭路共赏
Tasha:  我说我说如果我24号去北京
Tasha:  我他说不去打死我
Alice: 不去打死
Tasha:  我说住哪
Tasha:  然后他说麻麻利利的把公交票订下来
Katrina:  让妈妈
Tasha:  哈哈啊
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈你朋友是真人吧
Alice: 啊我的天
Jake: 北京任意点
Katrina:  不是怎么坐公交来这啊
Tasha:  嗯
Jake: 啥意思
Tasha:  北京任意点到郑州
Lucia: 可以坐公交去郑州
Tasha:  嗯
Lucia: 嗯
Alice: 我的天呐
Tasha:  上门接送
Lucia: 上门接送
Jake: 哈哈上
Alice: 我的天呐哈哈哈
Jake: 专车是吧
Jake: 专车才280
Lucia: 对我也想问
Lucia: 这么便宜
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: 比我高铁还便宜
Alice: 但是时间太长了屁股要坐烂了
Tasha:  10个小时
Tasha:  唉那好吧
Lucia: 在国内也没必要做什么Flex 8
Tasha:  9.5个小时
Lucia: 或者会所
Lucia: 巴士这种东西
Tasha:  到那再说开宾馆
Alice: 我看看
Alice: 绝了
Alice: 不是他是怎么能想到这条路的
Katrina:  儿子我能想到这条路
Alice: 我真是闻所未闻
Tasha:  他一会让我骑自行车过去哈哈哈
Alice: 你骑个小黄
Lucia: 救命
Jake: 北京到郑州自行车骑多久
Tasha:  啊
Tasha:  不知道
Lucia: 到地了饭就是
Jake: 就是五一
Lucia: 当地的消防接收站都不接收
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Alice: 调度费太贵了哈哈
Jake: 是
Tasha:  那我要用那种第一次的手机号去注册
Tasha:  然后他说新人首次可以免费调度
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Lucia: 你可以每路上
Lucia: 每到一个城市换一辆小黄
Lucia: 而这个城市之间还比较错
Tasha:  不是你在思考这件事的可行性吗
Lucia: 对对对
Tasha:  我到那要不要先治腿
Alice: 天哪
Alice: 为了盘醋包了盘饺子
Katrina:  这盘醋包了盘饺
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: 太好笑了
Lucia: 为了保证你能顺利去郑州玩
Alice: 闻所未闻
Jake: 导航郑州哪个医院好
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈哪个医院好
Jake: 骨科
Tasha:  我懂了就这样子
Tasha:  我在中途然后摔倒了
Tasha:  然后郑州开救护车过来接我哈哈哈
Jake: 哦
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: 哎压住了谁手机
Alice: 郑州确实有
Alice: 骨科医院
Alice: 离东站不是很远
Alice: 可以到了直接去哈哈
Lucia: 也不用去宾馆了哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha:  五一
Jake: 五一
Jake: 五一放几天
Alice: 没看
Lucia: 5天调休5天应该是
Jake: 7天吧
Alice: 休不够就请假
Tasha:  你你
Lucia: 我们还可以大胆一点休不够就翘课
Tasha:  对啊我今天就翘课了
Jake: 什么课啊
Tasha:  什么课不重要
Tasha:  我其实没见过他呢哈哈
Alice:你要跳舞吗
Jake: 好多人啊哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈好多人
Tasha:  哈
Alice: 好多人啊
Alice: 我看最近有什么演唱会的票今天晚上可以开始抢了
Katrina:  这舞还行这版本
Katrina:  一分五十 6
Tasha:  在北京的医院居然要抢
Tasha:  抢票你知道吗
Tasha:  是要提前7天的时候就要开始抢
Lucia: 哎我明明在充电它为什么又变成低电量了呀
Tasha:  那个医治的号
Jake: 那个我看一下
Tasha:  挂号费咋这么贵 100块钱
Alice: 你挂的是什么号啊
Katrina:  怎么又有SOLO啊
Tasha:  专家号
Alice: 那专家号是会贵一点
Jake: 呃没关系
Alice: 你会发现专家号也就给你诊疗个
Jake: 应该
Lucia: 可是我刚戴上的时候它还有30%
Lucia: 但是中间有那么小一小段线没插
Alice:一 点点时间
Tasha:  还有那种急诊预约挂号
Lucia: 直到你把充电宝给我
Tasha:  500块钱一个号
Lucia: 但是
Jake: 好
Lucia: 很奇怪
Jake: 我给你调个电多的
Alice: 急诊
Tasha:  嗯
Alice: 急诊还得预约
Tasha:  啊
Alice: 都急诊了为什么还要预约呢
Tasha:  就是紧急急诊预约号
Lucia: 其实充电宝里面蛮多的它有97
Tasha:  500块一个人
Jake: 嗯给你一个这个大的
Jake: 就是大的
Alice: 暂时还没有遇到过急诊的情况
Jake: 贵的
Tasha:  我们学校
Tasha:  校医院挂号都一块钱
Tasha:  你们学校也是是吧
Alice: 因为有补助是吧嗯
Lucia: 我们上医院刚开始就只要5毛钱
Lucia: 后来涨价到
Jake: 换一个
Lucia: 两块钱好过分了
Tasha:  那那是一块钱我
Jake: 对要保证上面的灯一直是亮着的
Jake: 他才能充
Alice: 张惠妹
Tasha:  然后每次开的药都需要提个麻袋去
Tasha:  去提是吧
Tasha:  哈哈是吧
Lucia: 哈哈哈是吧
Tasha:  对是的他给你开药都是10盒起开
Lucia: 对是的
Lucia: 我们校医院也开挺多的
Lucia: 没有这么夸张
Tasha:  这没有那么夸张吗
Tasha:  我每次
Lucia: 你是使用了夸张的修辞手法吗
Tasha:  哈哈没有使用夸张手法
Tasha:  我比如说呃我最近有点感冒
Tasha:  他会给我开说哪里感冒
Tasha:  你喉咙疼不疼
Tasha:  我如果说喉咙疼
Tasha:  他会给我开喉咙疼的药
Tasha:  喷喉咙的药
Tasha:  感冒灵颗粒解毒胶囊
Tasha:  哈哈开到一盒一种药就要开两三盒
Tasha:  那种可能就就不要钱吧
Lucia: 哦这个居然是2万毫安
Tasha:  然后他就一直开
Jake: 头疼医脑
Lucia: 头疼医全身
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Alice: 今年没有抢到一张票
Jake: 抢什么票
Tasha:  抢什么票
Alice: 演唱会的一张没抢到
Jake: 都有啥呀
Katrina:  我都找代抢了
Lucia: 让
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: 啊
Lucia: 让杨老板用他的那些设备帮你抢
Tasha:  设备帮你抢
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: 啊可以吗
Tasha:  开启加速器
Jake: 开启7台电脑
Katrina:  要搞一个Python脚本
Lucia: 因为他电脑多吗所以可以
Jake: 哈哈哈一样的
Jake: 那你猜这台电脑
Jake: 就是这些电脑每一台都都是租的
Jake: 然后租了十天
Jake: 每一台多少钱
Jake: 你猜就是十天多少钱
Jake: 多少钱一台
Tasha:  多少钱一台多少钱
Jake: 给个数给个数字吧
Lucia: 应该不会很贵吧否则他就会买了
Tasha:  一百块钱
Katrina:  我们学校竟然跳过这舞
Jake: 差不多我把我电脑借给你吧
Tasha:  我把我电脑借给你吧
Jake: 哈哈哈十天80啊
Tasha:  啊
Lucia: 10天80
Jake: 十天80
Tasha:  80一天
Lucia: 他说10天80
Jake: 十天一个电脑
Jake: 一台电脑八十
Tasha:  10天
Alice: 一天8块钱吗
Tasha:  一天才8块钱
Jake: 一天才8块钱
Jake: 对一台电脑一天8块钱
Alice: 还挺便宜
Jake: 可以不租了是吧
Lucia: 嗯确实很便宜
Jake: 哈哈
Tasha:  啊没有啊
Jake: 也可以租
Jake: 是吗我今天刷到这个
Katrina:  今天刷的这个5
Tasha:  呃
Katrina:  是我们计算机艺术团的还是我们学校的
Tasha:  才80块钱10天
Katrina:  我学姐在杭州上班哈哈
Lucia: 对我也在想居然
Jake: 哦
Tasha:  那我以后打游戏要不不买电脑了
Katrina:  对
Tasha:  去租电脑吧
Katrina:  这是他那年的毕业晚会
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈但是我觉得
Katrina:  他大四我大一
Lucia: 他租的电脑可能没有那么高配置
Katrina:  居然
Lucia: 就是简直是
Tasha:  哦垃圾电脑
Katrina:  我4年前就跳过你
Lucia: 我四年级
Katrina:  要跳舞吗哈哈
Lucia: 不知道问问他
Tasha:  弟弟得了一个怪病
Tasha:  要来北京治
Tasha:  他在我们县医院治不好
Tasha:  在扬州市医院治不好
Tasha:  在南京市医院也治不好
Katrina:  这太难了
Tasha:  然后要来北京医院寻医
Alice: 他怎么了
Tasha:  他长不高
Jake: 长不高
Tasha:  嗯
Katrina:  多大了
Tasha:  12岁
Alice: 缺什么维生素还是什么
Tasha:  可能吧
Tasha:  only  1米
Alice: 1米1米大概
Jake: 1 米1米是多少
Katrina:  突变了吗
Alice: 这
Tasha:  这
Jake: 我有卷尺
Jake: 好哈哈
Tasha:  啊不用
Katrina:  啊不用
Katrina:  那确实有点啊
Katrina:  12岁就这么点高
Tasha:  对
Katrina:  家长好着急
Katrina:  男生女生啊
Tasha:  男生
Alice: 他弟弟哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈妙啊
Lucia: 呵呵
Katrina:  哦哦我没听见前面
Tasha:  我觉得可能是生他生的比较晚
Katrina: 但激素啊
Katrina:  就是我有一个我爸爸同事就是他
Katrina:  他自己那叔叔就很矮
Katrina:  就是
Katrina:  小时候就跟他儿子打那种什么硬骨
Katrina:  骨骼发育的针
Katrina:  反正一年还要大几千块钱
Katrina:  因为怕他儿子长不高
Katrina:  因为那叔叔也就一米六
Tasha:  对
Tasha:  刚刚说要先来测骨相
Katrina:  对要测什么骨龄啊
Tasha:  看骨头还能不能再生长
Katrina:  12岁应该还可以吧
Jake: 对
Alice: 是不是还会测什么骨缝
Alice: 什么闭合酶之类的
Lucia: 要测
Katrina:  对对对要侧着
Lucia:  运动员也要测
Lucia:  那个
Lucia:  就是预测你接下来的身体发育情况
Lucia: 小时候测过
Jake: 想当运动员
Tasha:  当上了吗
Lucia: 没有没有不是不是
Lucia: 我其实不想当运动员
Lucia: 只是那会机缘巧合
Jake: 可以当运动员
Jake: 但是不想当
Tasha:  还记得小时候我们学哦
Tasha:  我上的班是什么国防班
Alice: 嗯
Tasha:  就是当兵当飞行员
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Tasha:  当时还有一批当飞行员的那个筛选
Alice: 你弟弟的高度有大概吧
Tasha:  嗯当时还有一批当
Tasha:  飞行员的筛选结果
Tasha:  前一天他体检前
Tasha:  我不小心把他耳朵给划破了
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哦
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 飞不了了
Tasha:  我还在想完了他要是飞行员不通过
Tasha:  会不会就全家要来找我麻烦
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈
Tasha:  就是飞行员身上不是不能有伤口吗
Alice: 嗯对
Tasha:  啊结果他成绩没有考过
Lucia: 嗯
Tasha:  哈哈
Jake: 虚惊一场
Lucia: 去惊一场
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈
Tasha:  呃幸不是我的问题首先
Jake: 对对对撇清关系撇清责任
Alice: 飞行员还得看视力
Tasha:  嗯
Lucia: 让我来看看我们的我们的备选
Alice: 就我们那个女女的宇航员刘洋嘛
Lucia: 我们的备选舞蹈
Katrina:  嘘这太
Tasha:  嗯
Katrina:  这个核心力量太吓人了
Alice: 他当时就是
Katrina:  什么时候能跳成这样啊
Jake: 可以就这个吧
Lucia: 他这个难度太高了
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Katrina:  这个是我开始玩的
Jake: 确实很高哈
Alice: 不对
Katrina:  我OK我关注up主
Lucia: 啊好厉害
Katrina:  我去这就力量型爵士
Alice: 就他曾经上的那个学校
Katrina:  就这样一下我脖子咔嚓一声哈哈
Tasha:  啊
Alice: 那个那个那个那个那个宇航员
Lucia: 啊好厉害
Katrina:  嗯喜欢看一些大佬跳舞
Alice: 他原来就是
Alice: 上学的时候就是参加选拔吗
Tasha:  啊
Alice: 就好多人被筛掉就是因为视力不过关
Alice: 但是他当时视力就蛮好的
Katrina:  哇
Katrina:  太厉害了
Tasha:  但是当飞行员视力都要很好
Katrina:  娜娜记录
Tasha:  然后身上没有伤口
Alice: 嗯是的对
Tasha:  然后好像还要转圈保持平衡
Katrina:  我我看一下
Katrina:  你要跳舞吗或者是
Tasha:  我也没有通过
Katrina:  然后跳舞嘛
Jake: 宇航宇航员
Jake: 宇航员
Katrina:  跟那个偶像万万岁
Tasha:  对哦不好意思是飞行员我
Jake: 对宇航员
Alice: 宇航员
Alice: 不好意
Katrina:  还有good time
Jake: 飞行员就要这样
Katrina:  呃就是这个
Katrina:  还不如good time对吧
Katrina:  然后猪猪侠我们排掉了
Tasha:  要不跳
Lucia: 啊什么排除的排吗
Katrina:  排除的排吗
Tasha:  yes OK
Katrina:  排除了OK OK
Lucia: OK OK
Jake: 哈哈哈哎呀我去
Katrina:  哎我可以跳yes OK可以
Lucia: 我看一下这个版本可以吗
Lucia: 看一下
Tasha:  哈哈哈我就会一个动作
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈是吧
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  可以跳yes OK其实也
Jake: 对很重要
Jake: 呵这是精华是吧
Alice: 杨超越那个是啥呀
Katrina:  差不多跟我高中跳那个
Tasha:  呃我不知道哎
Tasha:  创造101吗
Alice: 青春有你是谁啊
Katrina:  我那两个分不清哼
Katrina:  那两个节目
Alice: 有没有男团
Alice: 男团是啥
Katrina:  男团是那就是范丞丞他们出道
Katrina:  那个是什么来着
Tasha:  什么也是什么
Tasha:  创造101吗
Tasha:  我不清楚了
Alice: 时代少年团是谁啊
Katrina:  少年团是直接公司出道的
Katrina:  没有选秀那个
Katrina:  TF的那个家族
Tasha:  你要收回来吗
Jake: 没有我就玩
Alice: 我刚一折
Jake: 哈哈
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha:  好你最多能挑出来多少米
Jake: 对
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha:  我居然也想到了这个无聊的游戏
Jake: 他可能这个是这个
Jake: 这东西的上限跟人关系不大
Jake: 我感觉
Tasha:  我我其实刚刚想的就是挑战一下
Tasha:  最高能折多少米
Jake: 嗯
Tasha:  好我们来猜一下最高还能折多少米
Tasha:  谁能猜对
Jake: 呵呵呵把这全吃了
Tasha:  谁要是猜错了就把这些全吃了好吧
Jake: 那都全吃了
Tasha:  让我看一下现在多少米了
Jake: 那你看啥呀
Jake: 你要猜
Jake: 现在一米4243
Tasha:  好你猜多少
Jake: 我猜一米45
Tasha:  就是就就会折掉
Tasha:  我们以那个为失败
Jake: 哦
Tasha:  让我赌一米6
Alice: 我觉得你要完了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  后面 4个应该都是一样的
Tasha:  啊啊那我要赌一米五
Jake: 我也觉得你要完了啊
Jake: 那也差不多完了
Tasha:  你是一米多少
Alice: 哈哈哈 1米45
Jake: 一米一米四五
Tasha:  那我就赌一米六
Jake: 那你想吃你就
Alice: 没事反正哈哈
Jake: 吃吧你要不
Tasha:  那我赌一米555吧
Jake: 好
Jake: 你要多少
Tasha:  1米55
Jake: 一米55
Alice: 1米55跟一米45差10公哈哈
Jake: 你你自己来你自己来一米55
Jake: 哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈
Alice: 因为它越长它这个
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哇哦
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Alice: 你悄悄作一下弊
Alice: 你可以把你的手往前伸一点
Alice: 但也伸不了多远
Tasha:  哎好了啊可恶仔
Alice: 好了这才一米三多哈哈哈
Jake: 挺强的
Katrina:  因为副歌跳了3遍
Katrina:  其实他新动作不是很多哎
Jake: 挺强挺强
Alice: 没事
Alice: 我给你
Alice: 感觉这玩意会割伤手
Lucia: 我觉得这个也可
Jake: 嗯小心点
Katrina:  其实难度不大
Katrina:  我看了一下全是那个
Alice: 慢慢的
Katrina:  然后奔跑青春你还要再看一下吗
Alice: 有杠杆的感觉
Katrina:  奔跑青春跳出来蛮好看的
Tasha: 哎
Alice: 没关系没关系
Katrina:  但是感觉只能跳一分钟
Alice: 哎呀拉地了哈哈
Tasha:  啊哈哈别
Jake: 哈哈哈来吃开吃
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 这是用什么
Jake: 这是加了什么别的材料吗
Jake: 除了面面粉面粉鸡蛋没了
Alice: 就糖
Tasha:  面粉鸡蛋
Tasha:  yes
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: 这什么曲子
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Jake: 我去小孩吗
Jake: 这都
Katrina:  高中生
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: 嗯
Alice: 我真没见过蘸白糖的吃法
Jake: 真的吗对那确实可能只有那一片
Tasha: 真的吗
Alice: 嗯对
Jake: 哈哈哈
Alice: 但我们那有甜豆腐脑跟咸豆腐脑
Jake:是
Tasha:  那我们吃吃咸豆腐呢
Jake: 啊已经不记得了
Jake: 现在好像这什么店都能开
Jake: 已经不知道以前是什么味儿
Jake: 因为有很多外地的人吧
Jake: 所以什么味儿都有
Katrina:  嗯跳一分半
Katrina:  这一分半
Katrina:  感觉跟那个跟3分的差不多
Katrina:  看下yes OK
Katrina:  全网最详细版教程
Jake: 这后面什么字
Jake: 这是一个团
Jake: 哦好吧
Tasha:  狗剩子不知道
Alice: 谁是狗剩子
Jake: 我们后面也放一圈
Jake: 呵呵放一个什么呢
Lucia: 可以是自己设计一个logo哈哈
Jake: 哈哈可以
Lucia: 因为每个人就是练舞的studio就会在后面放上这个
Tasha:  哈哈是吧
Tasha:  不记得了
Jake: 哦
Alice: 坐你旁边吧
Lucia: 然后每次上完课之后
Lucia: 就会有人拿那个酷炫的那个有有
Lucia: 说什么云台的相机
Katrina:  可以跳yes okay了
Lucia: 然后给你录往前往后
Katrina:  哈哈其实可以跳yes okay
Jake: 哦OK OK
Lucia: 然后录出那种视频的效果
Tasha:  或者那个什么呃
Katrina:  我要不发群里
Katrina:  你们自己挑
Katrina:  说服一下那个修硕
Tasha:  啊他也要跳
Katrina:  哈哈不拉
Jake: 对
Katrina:  你来呗我最喜欢看男生跳女团舞了
Jake: 他可以跳
Jake: 我觉得可以
Katrina:  还可以我觉得
Alice: 我觉得跳起来没准比我们还
Katrina:  对比我们更妖娆的有可能
Lucia: 确实
Alice: 还还娇羞呢
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈娇俏哈哈哈
Tasha:  那个什么
Katrina:  这也不是很快吗
Tasha:  afterlike afterlike
Katrina:  Afterlife那是不是有点难
Tasha:  有点难吗
Katrina:  嗯那是女团舞
Tasha:  我看好多男生在网上跳那个仿舞
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha:  还有那个Dota
Katrina:  低头吗还是什么
Tasha:  到对头
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Katrina:  低头那有点难那个
Tasha:  那个有点难吗
Tasha:  他那个节奏很简单吧
Lucia: 这个确实不太难
Katrina:  他那个跳不出那个牛津斯的感觉
Katrina:  这还行是吧
Katrina:  这多少 1分 43 还行